we have the story from rep Anna Paulina
Luna this tweet's got 1.3 million hits
thousands of retweets she says just left
meeting for house oversight the FBI is
afraid their informant will will be
killed if unmasked based on the info he
has brought forward about the Biden
family
we're all very confused by the story
because we thought the FBI worked for
the neo-liberal establishment and the
neocons so do they not I guess some of
them don't
fascinating fascinating I mean I've had
on Kyle Serafin and Steve friend two of
the FBI whistleblowers I I know you've
had Kyle as well maybe you've even had
Steve I'm not sure but this story is
totally mystifying to me because I
honestly thought that the FBI was the
hit squad for America so the fact that
they're concerned about their
whistleblower being taken out I'm like
is that does that mean CIA does that CIA
or the Clinton Foundation yeah CIA well
let's read the news so this is the story
we have from today Comer says FBI says
Biden bribery probe ongoing and involves
shell companies house oversight
committee chairman James Comer said
Monday that an FBI informant file
accusing Biden of a 5 million bribery
scheme while he was vice president
involves shell companies and that FBI
officials told him it's part of an
active investigation coma reviewed the
informant file which she said came from
a highly credible informant in person at
the Capitol and told reporters
afterwards that he will move to hold FBI
director Christopher Wright in contempt
for not handing over a physical copy to
the panel the claims made in the
document are consistent with what we
found and disclosed to you all in
Romania it suggests a pattern of bribery
where payments would be made through
shell accounts and multiple Banks
there's a term for that it's called
money laundering so we feel this
accusation is consistent with a pattern
that we're seeing frankly in other
countries Comer said that FBI officials
confirmed that the unclassified FBI
generated record has not been disproven
and is currently being used in an
ongoing investigation the source
familiar with the review told the post
that names were redacted from the file
the FBI brought to the Capitol except
for the bidens now you know what I find
absolutely fascinating about this
the story it's really quite meaningless
because the the corruption of the Biden
family is overt
he actually is on camera saying gloating
that he went to Ukraine and said if you
don't fire the prosecutor I will
illegally withhold loan guarantees that
were approved by Congress which I have
no authority to do
so he just says he's doing it then we
have Tony bobulinski coming up being
like yeah they're taking bribes and 10
for the big guy and all that and
everyone's just like oh wow and now this
story comes out am I supposed to be
shocked I would hope not I mean you
cover the news every day so you
certainly know what's going down uh I
think that the interesting question
maybe the aliens are more important I
think it's just the Republicans gang up
on Biden he's such a nice guy how did
they do this to him it's just a sweet
old man and it is kind of like this
stuff comes out all the time and I'm
just like nothing's gonna happen nothing
changes like 10 for the big guy was how
long ago now like nothing changes I
remember the first time that I shared
with somebody the thing of him you know
talking about overt corruption in
Ukraine and they're just like well
that's you know RT it doesn't matter it
doesn't count like doesn't count it
doesn't matter he's it doesn't matter
where you're seeing the information
unless you're telling me that the actual
words he's saying are being faked
somehow you should be taking what he
says uh as the important part of it not
where you got the information well what
drives me crazy is that you have
Victoria Newlin on you know caught on
camera on Mike I guess you could say it
was a phone call between her and Jeffrey
Pyatt and you have that plus Biden
bragging about withholding a billion
dollars worth of Aid you have all of
these like uh you know whistleblowers
that have come out about different
things that transpired in Ukraine and
the lead up to Russia's Invasion and yet
if you bring it up it's apologia for
Putin somehow it's like that's so
nonsensical like they're the the the
ground work was being laid for that
Conflict for years and it's it's
infuriating that to just mention it
automatically means that I support
Russia's Invasion it's like no that's
I'm just trying to have a full spectrum
analysis of what's transpired I have a
theory
what if the Biden corruption story is
the distraction from the alien story
like the alien story comes out and
they're like oh cat's out of the bag
quick this is like the third time the
aliens have been a distraction I swear
yeah like Joe Rogan had something in
2020 right when quid pro quo came out
then suddenly aliens were real again
like it happens every six months now I I
am actually in the camp that I believe
that there is some some fire to this
smoke with the aliens like they've we've
been following this I mean if you're in
the conspiracy theory realm at all
you've been following this your entire
life so the fact that they're they're
now kind of like dribbling out more and
more factual evidence to support that
thesis I I tend to think that there's
probably something there but at the same
time the timing you know every time yeah
every time something happens I'm telling
you we just need to hold out if we stay
focused on the bidens long enough
they'll conform all kinds of things like
the JFK thing like who was behind that
I'm just saying if we can stay focused
they'll cave and give us their secrets
throwing out all of the uh like they're
declassifying everything in an effort to
hold back Joe Biden they're like oh no
uh Gulf of Tonkin JFK was assassinated
yeah aliens are real anything it's like
in Mario Kart when you have those shells
and you like fire them to like throw
your friends cars off course like
they're just releasing them to try and
get us to stop chasing this and I think
that tells you two things if you stay
focused you'll get a lot of other
secrets and also this is something
they're very scared of you talking about
if Biden screws up enough I'll be able
to find out if there actually is an
X-Files division at the FBI and that's
what I'm excited about I'm telling you
just stay focused the reality is these
people are probably in the scheme and
the reason why they're worried about
getting out is because they are the
criminals
that's it Biden can't do this alone
someone's got a cover for him someone's
got to look if Joe Biden is engaging in
business activities
of course that's going to hit the
intelligence agencies they're gonna see
these activities so someone has to be
going in and sweeping things up well I
think that's definitely true and I think
that the Epstein case kind of
demonstrated that as well where you know
once you have you start to see these
like these patterns of cover-ups that
that don't seem to make a lot of sense
but when you realize like oh this is
probably the build compromat on American
officials you're like oh no no I
understand why you guys are covering up
for them because this is all part and
parcel of the same operation I I mean
the Biden family
it's weird to think that the Biden
family of amongst all of the corrupt
American families is like now
starting to surpass many of them at
least in my eyes as far as like being
the most corrupt and and if they if
they're corruption in the attempt to
cover up their corruption leads to World
War III well then they go down as the
worst family in American history they're
the most corrupt do you think they're
the worst at hiding it at this point uh
that's a good question actually because
I think there's a distinct possibility
they're not the most corrupt but
um they are the most inept at their
corruption remember giving them lessons
if she was if they were actually paying
attention yeah Clinton would be yeah
that's true was good at it yeah remember
when
you know if you came out and said that
the country was being run
by powerful pedophiles in the private
sector and in government they said you
were a conspiracy theorist oh yeah and
then they were like you're crazy you're
a lunatic you're a crackpot far-right
conspiracy theorist and then Epstein and
then Maxwell and Maxwell got convicted
and is in jail and now they're like
committed suicide and they have a client
list of all of these high-profile heads
of state and government who were
flying around with this guy it's just
like but no one else has been prosecuted
you know it's just it's just you know
when this story first comes out and
people like hey I kind of think that
there's powerful you know child abusers
and government in the private sector
they're like ah you're crazy you can't
say that and then you'd go out and
regular people would be like oh you're
insane that's not true until it was true
yeah now they're like at least they're
not lizard people they're not lizard
people though yes they're crazy powerful
pedophiles in business and in government
but they're not lizard people
the next two are all ages drag show and
forget about these things the next story
that's gonna drop actually there are
lizard people you remember we were
talking about aliens they're lizards my
opinion is the whole cue Psy up was to
basically Poison the Well on people that
were actually hot on the trail of the
truth that there was actually sex
trafficking of children that was
happening at the highest levels of power
but then they they paired it with a
bunch of you know lunacy about how
Donald Trump was the savior of the
universe and we all just had to trust
the plan and it's like oh well that that
part happened to not be correct
unfortunately that once you start
getting close to something they try and
Veer you off course with aliens Mario
Kart shell things they're just lobbing
them backwards trying to blows up people
fall for it yeah I wonder how many
people are more interested in the aliens
than than this because the alien I think
the thing about the aliens is that it
has a profound impact on faith and
reality whereas Biden being corrupt is
like we know right you know what I mean
and I think it feels non-political like
people who don't want to talk about
politics will talk about aliens you know
it's harder for people to talk about
Corruptions because then you have to
weigh into like well your side did this
should we do that I mean simply put the
Joe Rogan podcast will now be leading
with aliens and not Biden corruption FBI
I mean look the story about the FBI
saying if our informant is unmasked
they'll be killed that's a salacious hot
political Story You've got like House of
Cards Vibes who could this guy be and
there's there's a deep throat in a
parking garage giving documents to
somebody and then aliens and now you've
got you know a Joe Rogan style podcast
and a whole bunch of them where they
would normally be like ooh spy thriller
story what's that aliens are real let's
roll yeah it does make me wonder if the
FBI isn't trying to rebuild some of its
uh I don't know reputation back if it
still has a reputation to rebuild upon
uh the fact that they're going after
Biden after they've been so obviously
biased in Prosecuting and persecuting
Donald Trump whereas they have
overlooked so much of what Joe Biden's
done I like maybe this is their attempt
to get back in the good graces and not
be defunded I'm not sure don't they want
to get him out of office anyway is
hasn't that always been kind of the plan
to a lot of people is that they didn't
expect him to serve a full term well
exactly it's serving up uh you know a
goat they thought it would be the age
thing and now they're like we'll just
we'll just Hammer you out it's just
hanging on we can't get rid of him we're
just gonna have to come up with
something else which tells you how like
if this were true it tells you how
incredibly unstable their whole
situation is I still can't fathom the
fact that Joe Biden is considered like
their the favorite for them like like
how is that even possible this guy
wasn't popular ever in my life he was
always like he wasn't popular when he
ran for president and won I know exactly
did you see James Vander Beek yep I know
you saw this Brett yeah where he's he's
he's filming himself being like you say
there can be no debate the man is 80 and
then you know everyone immediately took
it to be that he's saying there should
be a republican now he's just he's just
saying what we all know no Joe Biden I
don't know get you RFK they won't stand
for RFK no they keep referring to him as
like a fringe candidate he's a long shot
there's no way I think he's pulling in
number two yeah yeah well that's what
Vander Beek is pointing out he's like
look there's people that are pulling
high enough that at least make it a
question that you have to ask and if
you're saying that debates can't happen
if James Van Der Beek who is really just
a Hollywood you know he's a classical
liberal you know I think he moved out of
Hollywood anyways he moved to Texas
right but yeah he's like six kids I'm
telling you that guy's a conservative
he's he's pulling like a trolley of
children behind him as he's talking
about politics looking absolutely insane
it's awesome but it's like he's asking
valid questions look there's people
pulling at respectable numbers this is
not a done deal the guy's falling while
walking downstairs he's falling over
sandbags he's falling over just about
everything that are in his own feet and
even maybe that maybe we should have the
debates and see if he can form two
coherent sentences and they should drug
test them they should absolutely drug
test it yeah also I still want an
explanation as to why he wore a baseball
cap at the Air Force graduation that has
been bothering me since I saw that video
I thought was like an Air Force hat
though like I thought it was something
and has the president done that seems so
weirdly casual but I digress I gotta say
RFK Jr did a uh spaces today and I heard
a good chunk of it and
it's bizarre to me that like like I was
just saying Biden has never been popular
in this country like literally never
um and he's still not for the record
even though he's the president he's like
I don't know 25 approval rating or
something like that you listen to RFK
talk and I know everyone gives them a
hard time about his speech impediment or
whatever you want to call it the guy is
far and away from a Libertarian
perspective Far and Away the greatest
Democrat that I've ever seen or heard
speak in my lifetime he is phenomenal
his focus on defunding abolishing
reforming whatever scattering it to the
wind as his uncle once said the FBI and
the CIA that is extraordinarily high on
the priority list for Libertarians on
top of that he seems to have a better
grasp I mean I saw someone tweet out
today when you hear him speak about the
war in Ukraine it could have been
written by Scott horn or Dave Smith or
any of the libertarian anti-war
Advocates it's phenomenal his depth of
understanding is amazing even though his
son went over there and fought he still
seems to have a really good grasp on it
he seems to put as a very high priority
to avoid World War III avoid nuclear war
which ought to be particularly from the
Democrat Party which is allegedly
anti-war which it no longer is he's he
is like reconfiguring and realigning the
Democrat Party in real time and I am
both filled with gratitude and
absolutely horrified that he joins his
lineage in the in their legacy of how
the FBI has addressed his family so man
he's he's an interesting character yeah
he really is I think uh he
he claimed a lot of moderate to
left-leaning voters who feel
disenfranchised with the modern
Progressive Democratic party and feel
like they have some values that align
with it but don't feel like they're
represented overall I mean he is really
what they need even though they hate him
and don't want him and that really
mirrors to me what happened with Trump I
mean a lot of times Trump was extremely
patriotic he breathed life into the
Republican party in a way that it just
didn't have before and the party hates
him for it right I wanted to actually
make this point too I think that in the
the main election you would have RFK Jr
and DeSantis would probably be the best
candidates because I think they have the
most broad-based bipartisan appeal but
because of the way the primaries work
it's almost certainly going to be Trump
versus Biden and it's like that's once
again kind of shows the flaw I disagree
on that it's at his point oh you do yeah
his Charisma is like on a scale of one
to ten it's a 13. oh I grant you that
but I think that he's not going to be
able to Rally anybody he has more appeal
from the people that want to go back to
a more boring political atmosphere sure
but you know what I'm saying is those
people are politicos they're political
junkies any of them are conservative
there are many Independents but when I
talk to regular people they don't know
who he is they know very little so uh
they say things like oh yeah he'd
probably be better or something like
that or oh I don't know I just don't
like Trump things like that
they're going to have DeSantis will have
to go out and be more than just a
governor he's going to go on stage and
speak to people who don't know him
and he's not that good at it yeah and
that grant you that and I think Trump's
hilarious he's incredible he's like
probably the funniest politician in my
lifetime
um but I think I'm probably biased
because I I migrated from California to
Florida to live under DeSantis so it's
like I probably perceive him as being a
more legitimate threat than he is based
off the polls he doesn't appear to be a
threat at all to Trump which is honestly
quite surprising to me I mean the only
reason anybody's criticizing him is
because he's the only threat to Trump in
the primaries true no one's no one's
talking about Nikki Haley no one's going
oh Nikki Haley how dare you run against
Trump because nobody cares I mean it
sounds like she's being sponsored by
Halliburton for this entire run oh man
that that town hall rant she did on why
we should support war in Ukraine what a
joke was the most manipulative garbage
I've ever heard oh she's awful if we
don't stop them there then Poland's next
and basically we we have to risk world
war three to prevent world war three
it's like oh you're just a bloat soak
monster like every other you know she
was like we're we're here because world
war three is next and we're gonna stop
it it's like you're stuck yeah you're
making it happen thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time